all right this week in military news to
Marine pilots have been disciplined for
making a penis shaped flight path over
the skies of Southern California back in
October this this came to light when
some people people who track you know
flight paths noted that the path that
these two Marines had taken with their
their planes perfectly mimicked a dick
and balls when you when you looked at
the flight path so they did two of them
I said what I'm seeing here yeah right
there I'm not gonna right now there
there were two actually they so they
these guys both went up and we're like I
can draw a penis let's do it let's both
draw penises I thought they like
combined do you know what I mean - like
like a Blue Angels situation - to make
the sky penis but these guys each did
one on their own they I believe so yes
and the amazing thing about it is
they're perfectly drawn I mean they it's
not like they were like leaving
skywriting in the sky they were just
doing it in a way that they wanted
someone somewhere to notice this you
said perfectly drawn is that what your
penis looks like I just mean like the
two sides are the same it's like you
know it's about half they flew what have
you looked if you were in if you were on
the ground that day and looked up in the
air you would not have seen a piece no
which is what makes it even more badass
I think absolutely listen guys we talked
about respect for the troops this is why
when we talk about things like sacrifice
and loyalty and not taking a knee ever
even if it's not regarding this we don't
do that
to our troops we respect our troops who
risk their lives
to draw penises in the sky two of them
who's got two penises nobody but America
every penis in America we should be
thanking a soldier for if it's in the
sky
I'm glad these guys get to keep their
jobs I hope they get another job on top
of this one and this time they just get
to draw penises not just in the sky but
in the water we have a navy on the
ground we have troops on the ground if
we just put all of our servicemen and
women into the penis drawing industry
imagine imagine how great this country
may this world would be America go on to
our next story which our last story yeah
about the world the football again in as
you mentioned to start out last week's
show Anthony you know the country's been
mourning the loss of former President
George HW Bush and disrespectful thing
you can do after someone dies is ladies
and gentlemen the President of the
United States it's it's insanely
disrespect we're gonna be hearing from
secrets honestly I think there's one
thing you could do that would be more
disrespectful to George HW penis over
his funeral I think he was he was kind
of into skydiving wasn't he he was a big
time you look really like skydiving he
loved the military mm-hmm I think he'd
be and doesn't love the military bring
him to me I think one thing you could do
that's even more disrespectful he's talk
about the former president looking down
from heaven why don't we just listen to
this clip but to set it up this speaking
right now is before we did let me set it
this up even further
remember the XFL yeah remember that yeah
it was embarrassing
well it's back its back and they
announced this week last week where the
franchises are going to be and the most
objectionable part of this press
conference announcing where the teams
were going to be is from Janice Burke
the CEO of the Houston Sports Authority
who is very proud to bring in XFL
franchise to her hometown
I know that in Houston we are mourning
the loss of an iconic man today he was a
huge sports fan we will miss him dearly
but I can't help but think he's looking
down from heaven and he's pleased to
hear this news
did anyone like boo this is like the day
after too this is this is a week ago now
i that that we're listening to this and
this was right after he passed away
that's uh okay like how would he know
like how would he have found out if he
was looking down from heaven like where
did he get that information is he
watching like ESPN Oh Cho or something
like it's not like this is breaking news
all across the sports network correct
you're Jewish you don't really
understand how heaven works when you're
in heaven you can just look down and
smile it whatever you want you can like
see things almost like your God himself
like you don't have to watch you don't
have to just like they don't give you
cable you know I mean but I'm just like
how boring is heaven if you die and
you're like what the XFL is doing what
like in like a day and like you're in
heaven for all of eternity but the first
day I don't they're like I lose a little
bit of like pull me back in like what if
he just like sat up in his coffin like
he was just like I can't be dead
we've been having an XFL team this is I
got to come like this she think he's
like checking the scores of the Rockets
game to like Oh tough loss for the
Rockets against the Clippers last
because he's in heaven crying he's in
heaven crying over the over the Rockets
cuz that would be a lot bigger
news than the XFL coming back in three
years by the way I mean what is the odds
that that team or that game ever even
happened there's gotta be like 50/50 at
best
I don't know now that they got Bush on
their side and he's up in heaven what he
can really make things happen you know I
bet he's smiling down right now on us
talking about sky penises I'll tell you
what Barbara Bush was up in heaven
furious about this furious about the XFL
CFL fan big time
[Music]
you